the first time we saw zombies in Star
Wars was in the animated series The
Clone Wars in the season 2 episode
Legacy of Terror in this episode Anakin
Skywalker and Obi-Wan Kenobi discovered
that the geonosians have a secret weapon
brain worms that can reanimate and
control dead bodies the second time we
saw zombies in Star Wars cannon was in
the season 4 episode Massacre of the
Clone Wars in this episode General
Grievous invades the plane of damir the
night sisters use their magic to raise
their dead sisters as zombies and send
them to attack Grievous and his droid
army the fourth time we saw zombies in
Star Wars cannon was in the live action
series Ahsoka these are stormtroopers
who have been resurrected by nightsister
Magic using a chant of Resurrection the
first time we saw zombies in Star Wars
Legends was in the 2009 novel death
Troopers by Joe shriber this novel
follows a group of survivors on an
imperial prison barge infested with a
bioweapon called project Blackwing or
the sickness the second time we saw
zombies in Star Wars Legends was in the
2010 novel red Harvest this novel
follows a group of Jedi and Sith who are
trapped in a Sith Academy that's overrun
by zombies